Christopher Benson what is death of
innocence about death of innocence is
the story of Mamie till Mobley and her
son Emmett Till at its heart it is a
mother and son story and it's one that
takes a horribly tragic turn but at the
same time it's the story of a mother's
journey the journey for redemption the
journey to to find justice in the the
horrible brutal murder of her son Emmett
Till was 14 years old in 1955 when he
traveled from Chicago is Chicago home to
the Mississippi Delta to spend a couple
of weeks with relatives and this was
going to be the adventure of a lifetime
for a kid who is so full of energy and
life the wide open spaces of the Delta
and all the wonderful adventures he had
heard about within a few days of his
arrival there was an incident that
occurred at a store in money Mississippi
a few days after that he was kidnapped
by white racist in the middle of the
night and brutalized over the course of
several hours his body was found several
days after that in the Tallahatchie
River and this story really would have
ended at that point as so many other
lynchings had had ended throughout
throughout history except for the
courage of his mother and several key
decisions that she made that kept this
story alive and shared it with the
entire country how did you get involved
in the story well I was introduced to
Mamie till Mobley by a mutual friend I
had grown up knowing something about the
story I was a journalist and as any
journalist I was inquisitive I wanted to
know something about her I just wanted
to meet her she's an icon and so in the
course of our discussion at her house
she just blurted out I want to write a
book I want to write a book and I had
done a novel already and my friend knew
that and he said well if you want to
write a book maybe you should talk to
this guy he writes books and that's how
it started this was June 2002 and within
a month we were talking seriously about
her story and even before we completed
all the legal things that you have to do
we had we had started working on it in
earnest
and six months later she had died and
thankfully we had covered the story and
were able to move forward with a book
that had meant so much to her over the
course of nearly fifty years why did the
name Emmett Till mean something to you
well I was 10 years old when I first saw
the picture of Emmett Till the famous
picture that was published in a number
of periodicals starting with Jet
magazine they carried it national and
then the Chicago Defender
the picture of the brutalized body of
Emmett Till was was publicized around
the country and I think it left an
impression on me at 10 years old I was
horrified I mean I was 10 he was 14 you
know he was so close to my age that it
it occurred to me that something that
had happened that was so horrible to
this kid could happen to me and in my
ten-year-old consciousness what I saw
was that this this child had been
brutalized had been murdered because he
was black and that there were people out
there who could hate me just because I
was black and hurt me so in a way the
the murderers of Emmett Till not only
hurt him his mother and so many people
who were close to him but they
victimized so many other people as well
I mean looking at that picture has been
something of a rite of passage for so
many black kids over the course of a
couple of generations it certainly
affected my life it horrified me in a
way it stripped away the protection of
my childhood where did you live I lived
in Chicago and he was from Chicago so I
felt a commonality there what were
holiday today I'm 15 and what were your
circumstances growing up well you know
we had a difficult set of circumstances
my mother was raising us by herself and
she had to work so you know we learned
something about what it was like to have
to really work hard to to succeed and it
wasn't unlike the experience that Emmitt
had with his mother who for many years
was you know was the only parent he knew
now before I show the picture for
someone I hadn't seen it
describe what we're going to see what
where was this picture taken and
approximately what date okay image body
was returned to Chicago on this
second of September 1955 and his mother
as I said make several critical
decisions one was to insist that his
body be returned to Chicago Mississippi
authorities wanted his body buried
immediately in Mississippi to I guess
put an end to this story she insisted
that he be returned so that was the
first critical decision she they moved
heaven and earth to to get his body back
it came under lock and seal from the
state of Mississippi the the box was was
sealed and there were orders not to open
the box she insisted that the box be
opened because she wanted to look at her
son one more time before she buried him
so that was the second critical decision
and then in the course of looking at the
body she decided that there should be an
open casket funeral that the world
should see the horrible face of race
hatred when what had been the beautiful
face of her son so the picture that that
we included in the book is a picture
that was shot of of Emmitt in the casket
by Jet magazine and by the Chicago
Defender that was was shared with
readers around the country and what it
shows is the condition that Emmitt was
returned to his mother in after being in
the Tallahatchie River for several days
he was horribly disfigured he was
brutalized and she in a very painful way
describes what she saw in the book but
the picture of course speaks to that as
well at the time who published this
picture it was published in Jet magazine
and it was also published in the Chicago
Defender and I think other publications
picked it up after that and since that
time as you went through the research on
this how often did you find it well it's
it's on the web it's you can look at it
online other publications haven't shown
this precise picture some have shown a
picture of Emmitt in the casket from it
at a distance and we have that picture
as well from the balcony of the Roberts
temple Church of God in Christ where his
funeral was held so there are different
angles on the casket and you say in the
book that they had Plexiglas around the
casket yes it was glass and clothes and
how many people walk by this casket it
was reported that dead at least a
hundred thousand people walked by the
casket in Chicago
mother Mobley made a decision after
viewing his body that she wanted to let
him lie in state for four days and he
did and during the course of the four
days at least a hundred thousand people
filed by and they were visibly moved I
mean I've seen a documentary since then
and you see the looks on the faces of
the people who are about to enter you
see the the reaction as they leave and
as mother Mobley writes every fifth
person needed assistance just to get out
of the church people were fainting
people were crying they were visibly
moved at the sight of his body so the
picture is on the screen at this stage
he's how old he's 14 he had just made 14
as a matter of fact he was murdered in
August of 1955 and his birthday is in
July so in July 55 you just turned 14
now what his mother describes as seeing
at the time is not quite what we're
seeing in this picture right he was um
he was brought back to Chicago by a a
rain or funeral home
in in the city and even though she
wanted in its body to be viewed
untouched she wanted the world to see
what she had seen the funeral director
there did do something to at least try
to prepare him for for viewing but what
you see is the best that they could do
apparently what impact did this have
well as I say people were horrified I
think that what you see on the faces of
the people who are about to enter the
church is is a resolve in some cases you
see anger you see great pain but you see
a resolve it's as if you know people are
saying okay this is where we draw the
line and from what I understand and what
she writes about in the book that she
heard from so many people is that this
is the single event that energized them
that activated so many people to become
involved in the civil rights movement
and as we know in 1955 the modern civil
rights movement was just really taking
hold this was a year after the Brown
versus Board of Education decision and
the summer that the second part of that
came down so people were were ready to
to take a stand as a result of seeing in
its body
they said this is as bad as it can
possibly get we're going to determine
not to let it get any worse than this so
it energized an entire movement
according to the people who participated
Rosa Parks would later tell mother
Mobley when they became good friends
that you know she was thinking about a
good many things when she decided not to
give up her seat on a bus in Montgomery
only three months after the trial of
him--it's murderers she said she was
thinking about a good many things but
she was thinking about Emmett Till as
well and she couldn't be moved and so
many people have said that they were
energized by this and became involved
there were many people who were who were
in its age at the time of his murder who
came of age at the peak of the civil
rights movement as we know the civil
rights movement Eric to rise by by the
youth by the young people who
participated in the sit-ins and the
Freedom Rides
in the law was a killer ever found the
yes the two people were put on trial as
I say an incident occurred at a store in
money Mississippi we're not entirely
clear on what happened but Emmitt and
some friends and some cousins were at
the store what's the name is door it's
Brian's grocery and meat market and
money Mississippi where his money money
is in the Mississippi Delta and Emmitt
was staying near the town and you call
it a town but it's really as somebody
said a wide place in the road it was a
what we might call now a commercial
strip but people live near the city at
the town and and image relatives live
nearby if you fly into Memphis and I
know folks did to get there how far is
it down I fifty five to get there it's
from what I understand about an hour and
a half two hour here have been there no
no I wanted to go I wanted to go in
September of 2002 but we were working so
hard on the book at that time that I
didn't have a chance to go I wanted to
go at that time because he was murdered
in August the trial occurred in
September and I wanted to be there
somewhere in that period to experience
what it must have been like for for
to be there at that time and for his
mother to go down to testify at the
trial it didn't work out then after she
passed I was invited to come down again
and at that point I decided I wouldn't
I'd wait until after the book was done
because I didn't want my perception at
that point to color the the portrayal
that we were that we were putting
together for the book it had to be her
story at how to view her words but in
answer to your question there was a
trial the the killers were apprehended
and they confessed right away to the
County Sheriff that they had taken
Emmitt from the home where he was
staying at two o'clock in the morning
they said they had come in they had
taken him away and they wanted to
identify him as the person who had done
whatever it happened at the store and
they said he was not the right kid so
they let him go and they let him walk
the three miles from money back to the
the farm home where he was staying
so they confessed to that much of it but
they later confessed after they were
acquitted they later confessed to the
killing itself they confessed in great
detail to a journalist who wrote a story
a famous story now for Look magazine
they didn't implicate any other people
but there are a number of people who
have said since then that there were at
least seven maybe ten people who are
involved in this this killing the
abduction the cover-up but there was a
trial Roy Bryant and JW Milam his
half-brother were put on trial for the
murder of Emmett Till and this picture
right here which ones which to my left
is Roy Bryant and the person in the
middle is his half-brother JW Milam Roy
Bryant owned the store with his wife
Brian's a grocery and meat market and on
the day Emmitt and his friends and
cousins visited that that store within
just a few days of arriving in
Mississippi he Roy Bryant was not there
his wife was and something happened at
the store that obviously changed the
course of events in history it was
reported that there was a whistle and
there have been people who've said well
Emmitt was actually whistling at a
checker move
the porch just outside he was a checker
player and there was always a game going
on on the porch outside he saw a bold
move and he whistled at it that was one
version of the story another was that he
whistled at the woman at Carolyn Bryant
the wife of Roy Bryant as a prank never
knowing what that would have meant in
the Mississippi Delta in 1955 and the
other version of the story is that he
had a terrible stutter and he had had
polio when he was about five years old
and while he recovered the full use of
his legs he did have some muscle damage
that affected his speech so he had a
stutter that his mother tried to help
him work through she did in a number of
ways one of which was to get him to stop
steady his breathing by whistling and
there was at least one cousin who was
there at the time who told a reporter
that when he talked he sometimes made a
whistling sound and so Mamie till Mobley
went to her grave believing that that's
what happened that in an effort to
describe to his friends what he had
bought in the store two cents worth of
bubblegum that he had gotten stuck on
the word whistled to get his to work his
way through it and that Carolyn Brian
was what bryant was offended by it and
everything else unfolded from there and
it's a horrible thing for a mother to to
consider that the one thing that she
taught her son in the hopes that he
would have a better life may in the end
of cost in his life it was a terrible
tension for her to carry with her
forever on page 185 when you have
Carolyn Bryant recounting her story you
say when she held her hand out for the
money she claimed that he grabbed her
arm and spoke to her quote how about a
date baby
unquote she said she broke free and that
he came around and grabbed her by the
waist and spoke again quote what's the
matter baby can't you take it I've been
with white women before unquote you
spent a lot of time leading up to that
point describing what kind of a young
man he was and was there anything in his
past that would lead anyone to believe
he would say things like that
no not according to what is
mother had set out and then you know as
a journalist I was curious about what
other people might say as well so I
talked to people who were there at the
time not that I have wanted to question
what she said about the story but
because I was curious and I wanted to
make sure there were no credibility
problems and going forward with with the
book and there were people who were
there I talked to them cousins and and
friends and they said he wasn't in the
store long enough to have done any of
that one cousin went into the store and
made a purchase he was leaving as Emmitt
came in and why limit was there another
cousin stood at the door and the cousin
who stood at the door said that never
happened other people who were around at
the time said he wasn't even in the
store long enough for any of that to
have happened so what we have here is
the testimony of a woman at trial a
month after the event and a belief on
the part of many people that this story
was enhanced to justify if you can
justify what was done to this kid that
he had crossed the line of southern you
know custom at the time and that he
deserved to be punished that was the
story that they had fared in the
community there and the story that from
what I understand the jurors had heard
long before the trial ever occurred at
1955 when he was killed you say that in
Tallahatchie County there were 11,000
whites and 19,000 black right what was
what were the rights of blacks in that
year in that state Wells asipi there was
not a single black person who was
registered to vote and I think that
pretty much says everything at this time
and again this is a year after the
initial decision in Brown versus Board
of Education and just a couple of months
after the implementation order that the
Supreme Court had handed down that that
school desegregation should proceed with
all deliberate speed well that didn't
change everything immediately by way of
law in this country or at least as a
practical matter I mean schools took a
long time as we know to to start
desegregating it activated whites in the
South who were terribly afraid that
their way of life was going to change
and they set out systematically to
enforce the old way of the south and
that enforcement gained official
sanction so people were intimidated they
were they were intimidated you know when
they tried to register to vote and
obviously was effective as you see in
Tallahatchie County people were not only
subject to economic reprisal and it was
it was severe I mean you had white
citizens councils throughout Mississippi
who I heard described as the KKK and
business suits who would publish lists
of registered voters and if there were
blacks who had attempted to register
they were fired from their jobs their
home mortgages were were foreclosed on
and they were not allowed to buy seed
for planning if they were farmers they
could not get low loans for equipment
they were driven out of business and
there was no forgiveness even after they
would remove their names from the voter
rolls they still were not allowed to to
have a livelihood so it was a horrible
State at that point but beyond the
economic reprisals people were actually
murdered for attempting to exercise
their rights
just before Emmitt arrived in
Mississippi Reverend George Lee in
nearby belzoni was murdered he was an in
double-a-c-p leader in the state he was
murdered for attempting to register
people to vote it was there was a major
cover-up of his murder and you know the
sheriff said well it wasn't a shotgun
blast as everybody had had determined
but it was in fact a car accident he was
he was shot as he was driving down the
highway and even though the lead pellets
were retrieved the the sheriff denied
that that ever happened another person
Lamar Smith was murdered in nearby
Brookhaven just two weeks before him and
arrived in Mississippi he was trying to
pass out leaflets in the town square in
broad daylight on a Saturday afternoon
he was approached by several white
citizens who
shot him in front of so many witnesses
who never saw a thing so this was the
the the condition of life for for blacks
in Mississippi there were rights but you
could not exercise your rights so after
he was in the store at Bryant's what
happened then what time of day was that
this was in the evening this was um at
the beginning of cotton-pickin season
and and he was just visiting therefore
he was visiting yeah and you know he was
having a lot of fun this was several
days after he had arrived in Mississippi
and a group of the kids went into went
uptown as they called it to buy some
treats that's what they did at the end
of the day after picking cotton all day
they had supper and in the early evening
they would drive up town and just sort
of hang out so this was about 6:00 or
7:00 in the evening what happened next
well they went into the store as I
mentioned one at a time basically and he
made his purchase and left as people
have recounted and there was the whistle
and at some point somebody said you know
that they were gonna get in trouble
because of that because it looked like
the woman Carolyn Bryant was offended so
they jumped in the car and drove away as
they were driving there's a very
dramatic scene that people had described
to to mother Mobley of a light appearing
and behind them headlights from a car
they thought they were being chased and
they all ran through the cotton field
they stopped the car and ran through the
cotton fields to hide and as it turned
out it was just a car passing so within
a few days of that nothing had happened
and everybody felt that this whole thing
would pass there was no problem and
that's when Roy Brian and JW Milam came
to to the house of image relatives and
and dragged him out where'd they take
them that is is is one of the questions
that hasn't fully been answered they
described a circuitous route through the
road Bryant and JW Milam described the
route that they they took him on through
the back roads of the Mississippi Delta
there is at least
a report by several witnesses that they
stopped in a nearby County sunflower
County at a plantation that was managed
by one of my lumps brothers Leslie Milam
there were witnesses who actually
testified at trial black witnesses who
testified at trial that they saw Emmitt
in the back of a pickup truck with two
black men sitting there holding him and
several white men in the cab they saw
the truck later parked at a shed on this
plantation they saw JW Milam coming out
periodically with a gun strapped to his
waist and taking water they heard
beating inside the the shed and they
heard moans from what what they believe
was was Emmitt and later they saw the
truck pull closer to the shed put
something in there and cover the back
with a tarp and everyone believed that
was in its body or they take him they
took him to the Tallahatchie River where
he was dumped now the the version of the
story that that Roy Bryant and JW Milam
told to Alec magazine was that that
Emmitt was defiant that they had just
roughed him up a little bit to teach him
a lesson but that he was defined up to
the point of standing at the edge of the
Tallahatchie River and in effect dared
them to to kill him and that would have
been impossible as you see the condition
of his body he was so savagely beaten
that he likely couldn't even stood at
that point and he very likely was
already dead when he was carried to the
to the river they tied a gin fan around
his neck with barbed wire how heavy is a
gin fan uh about 75 pounds there were
wide reports on the weight of it 75 to
150 pounds but it was about 75 pounds
according to most accounts and they
rolled it into the river and dragged his
body there and his body was discovered
only a few days later when another
teenager was out in the river fishing
and one of Emmet's legs had risen to the
top and was was seen and that's how he
was
when they discovered the body what
happened then well he was pulled ashore
and he was not recognizable except for a
ring that he wore on his the middle
finger of his left hand and as it turned
out that was a ring that his mother had
given to him just before he left for
Mississippi it was a ring that had been
left by his father a soldier in Europe
during World War two and she had given
it to him he had tried it on for you
know off and on for many years before
that it never really fit it was kind of
a loose fit even then but he wanted to
wear it he wanted to show it off to his
his friends and cousins in Mississippi
and brag about his father who had been a
soldier as it turns out he allowed one
of his cousins to wear that ring while
they were playing around in the field
and his cousin was able to help identify
him through the ring before we move on
there is a story about his father that
mother Mobley found out later his father
you got a picture of him in here Louis
til right and what was a story and when
did she find it out the story was that
at when Emmet was about four his father
was these are the bottom picture he's
the bottom picture and I don't know if
you can get close in you can see the
ring on his finger
oh there he's in Italy at the time and I
believe this is 1943 or 40 for him it's
father Louis Till was killed during the
war as his mother believed as Mamie till
Mobley believed she got notice of that
when him it was was four but as it turns
out he was executed after the war and
she had tried over the course of many
years to find out what had happened what
she received was a notice from the
military that the spousal allotment was
being terminated it actually was an
allotment for Emmet
and she never really knew what the cause
was except that the language in the
letter included the words willful
misconduct it was only after the murder
trial that the cause was publicized and
she discovered then that Lewis Till was
accused of murder rape and murder in
Italy and that he was executed the
execution order was signed by General
Dwight David Eisenhower and it was a
curious thing to her because after that
I mean it came as a shock to her and it
came after the murder trial but before
the grand jury was to be convened to to
consider a kidnapping charge which was
separate from the murder and she
believed always that this was a
deliberate attempt to influence the
grand jury which didn't hand down an
indictment as it turns out the reporters
who covered that story the revelation
about Louis Till admitted that they got
the information they got which they
couldn't have discovered from the the
Department of Defense they got that
through the help of Senator James
Eastland of Mississippi at the time who
was a staunch segregationist and one of
the leaders in the movement to establish
the white citizens councils in
Mississippi and the effort to resist the
enforcement of Brown versus Board of
Education so she always believed that
that was a deliberate attempt to change
the course of events as it turns out
mother Mobley talked to a number of
lowest hills army buddies after this she
talked to her own brother-in-law she
later married and her brother-in-law had
also served in Europe during the war and
it seemed that this was a common thing
that occurred among blacks in the
military who were marched out at you
know 2:00 in the morning or so and told
to lineup and identified by women in
Europe as men they had had relations
with or men they were accusing of
something and there's a book that's
going to be coming out soon that deals
with this that during the course of the
war there were many more
black soldiers and whites who were
accused of such crimes even when they
were unfounded and court-martialed and
executed so we don't know what really
happened in this case I want to come
back to the situation with Emmett Till
in just a second again this was 1955 a
couple of quick things the civil rights
bill of 57 and of 60 and of 64 were what
and how much did this incident have to
do with moving the civil rights bill of
57 along well primarily the the civil
rights bill of 57 during the course of
the congressional hearings there was
testimony about Emmett Till the trial
and the the lack of justice
in in the case and there are many who
believe that that was influential in
getting that first civil rights bill
through and as a result the office of
the assistant attorney general for civil
rights was established and the u.s.
Commission on civil rights was
established among other things so there
was probably the most tangible effect of
of this this this event the later civil
rights acts really were by and large a
result of the civil rights movement
starting with Brown versus Board of
Education and the the movement that was
energized as a result of a series of
events really Brown certainly told us
all that that progress could be made
Rosa Parks and the the Montgomery bus
boycott that lasted for more than a year
helped to encourage people to to
demonstrate to participate in the
movement and they were in fact as many
people have said energized by what they
saw during the course of events it with
in its murder and the the trial and the
the the courage that so many people
showed as a result of you know coming
forward to testify the sequence though
54 was Brown 55 was this murder right
and then how about the march to some of
the Birmingham bombing and as well
during the 60s Rosa Park happened when
in also in 55 it the the murder of
Emmett Till occurred in August of 55
August when
viii the trial was in late September and
the Montgomery bus boycott started in
effect in December of 55 and again
before we return the story your
background where did you you say Griffin
Chicago how many kids in the family
there two of us my sister who's a
children's book writer in illustrator
and your mother did what freely
she was once she was in show business
many years ago she was a dancer but
while we were coming up she was she was
a secretary did you ever know your dad
no and you went where to school well we
lived in Chicago for the most part so I
went to school through grade school in
Chicago we also lived in Los Angeles so
I attended school there and then we
moved to New York where I attended high
school and about college where'd you go
what just college we moved back to
Illinois so I studied at the University
of Illinois I earned my bachelor's and
my master's degrees in journalism there
and then I became a journalist was
writing for Ebony magazine for years and
transferred to Washington I was
Washington editor and then took leave to
to attend a Georgetown to study law did
you get your law degree yes I did
are you practicing law I'm not
practicing now immediately after law
school I thought actually I was going to
continue writing my intention was to
return to the Washington bureau of Ebony
and to write with the substantive
foundation but I was returned to Chicago
I went on corporate side for the company
and I was in House Counsel for about 13
years and then returned to writing after
that how big is that Johnson publishing
operation now with ebony ebony is
probably the largest circulation black
magazine in the country it is actually
it's got 1.8 million paid circulation a
total readership of about 11 million and
Jet magazine is roughly a million and
multiple of about five times for
pass-along so the magazine's reach a
good number of people who runs it now
well Johnny Johnson is the founder the
publisher and the CEO the a chairman of
the board
his daughter Linda Johnson rice is the
CEO now and this book was finished when
what date
it was finished in April of 2003 and it
was published in October and when did
again did she die she died in January of
that year January 2000 so she never saw
the publication she never saw the actual
book she saw the progress it would be
that we were making though and she took
great joy in that and where do you get
that the name mother Mobley well partly
because she she inspires that in you
when when you beat her so many people
looked upon her as a mother you know she
never had another biological child but
she embraced so many children during the
course of the remaining years that she
had after him it's murder she was a
schoolteacher for 23 years she was an
active church member during that entire
period and she formed the Emmett Till
players during the course of her her
years as a teacher the Emmett Till
players were groups of students who she
taught speeches by dr. Martin Luther
King jr. too and so she wanted to teach
them a sense of history she wanted to
teach them the connection to Emmett Till
and all these students hundreds of
students she was able to reach and touch
looked upon her as a mother figure she
became a church mother it's a rank in
the church where you know you you reach
a certain level where you can influence
and guide other women in the church so
she was proud of the fact that she'd
become a church mother so it's also an
official title that she carried this is
a picture of her hand at the Civil
Rights Museum Memorial and civil rights
memorial in Montgomery at the
headquarters of the Southern Poverty Law
Center she was there for the dedication
and she part of the memorial it's a
Milan sculpture black granite same woman
that did the Vietnam Vietnam Memorial
there's a there's a table with a
fountain that flows over the table and
it's it's a continuum of all the or many
of the martyrs of the civil rights
movement and in Mathilde's name is
engraved there so that was a picture of
her actually touching his name
and it's quite a moving experience for
her and she was born where she was born
in Mississippi not far from where this
occurred and Hazlehurst and when did she
leave there she left there when she was
two years old to Chicago her family
moved to Chicago and as was the case
with so many families moving out of
Mississippi her mother and she left
first her father stayed on to just tie
up some business
farming accounting for the the
sharecropping crops that they had
processed so they left in the early fall
he left in in December and they they
settled near Chicago in Argo whose Papa
Mose Papa Mose is Emmett's great-uncle
and the person he was staying with in
money Mississippi Papa Mose is quite a
hero in the story he was the person who
tried to stand his ground when these two
men came in with guns at two o'clock in
the morning and took him in a way he
later stayed on to testify at the trial
and had the courage to stand in a
courtroom in the Mississippi Delta in
1955 and point to two white men and
accused them of a crime nobody had ever
heard of that happening in Mississippi
and he did it a great risk to his life
and is considered one of the many unsung
heroes of the civil rights movement
because of that so many people saw the
image you just showed and were
encouraged by it they were inspired by
it that bravery that courage that he
showed and in doing that helped so many
other people to you know to gain the
courage they needed to to do sometimes
the most simple things I mean people
talk about the stand that Rosa Parks
took as his mother Mobley would say she
took a stand by keeping her seat so many
people say such a simple Act but it was
a simple act of great courage great
bravery because at the time you risked
your life in taking that kind of stand I
don't think enough people understand
that now because we're in the courtroom
for the moment just a couple of things
you point out in the book that there
were 22 seats for white reporters and
for for black reporters initially and
they said what was that about why so few
for black reporters well the people
didn't understand it at that time the
sheriff of the county had all the power
in accounting and the sheriff at this
time HC Strider
was a horrible racist you know he made
no bones about that and he was
determined that during the course of
this this huge media event what-what
David Halberstam
would call later the the first big media
event of the civil rights movement
Strider was determined that black and
white reporters were not going to
co-mingle he was going to enforce
segregation in his courtroom and he
considered to be his courtroom even
though the judge was presiding he was in
charge of every institution in that that
community and so he had set aside four
seats for black reporters off to the
side as it turned out this the event of
the trial gained so much notoriety that
there was something like a hundred news
reporters and photographers who had come
down to Sumner Mississippi where the
trial was held and it was difficult to
accommodate this great number they
wanted being about 12 black reporters
and photographers who came and so they
wound up fashioning a table for the
black reporters to to be seated at and
it was a quite a rough table as mother
Mobley described it it was it was so
rough that she tore her skirt on the
splinters as she tried to scoot her seat
up to it
this was not just the Jim Crow table for
the reporters as it turned out but it
was the table where some of the
witnesses like mother Mobley were seated
and in fact a u.s. congressman people
white people in Mississippi were
astounded when congressman Charles Diggs
from Detroit showed up to observe the
trial and they didn't believe at the
time that there was any such thing as a
as a black congressman in fact one
sheriff's deputy remarked and these are
his words that were reported a [ __ ]
congressman it it's not possible it's
not even legal finally he was able to
can
Bentsen that he was a congressman and he
also was seated at the Jim Crow table in
this picture also is Simeon Booker here
with the glasses I believe who was Jet
magazine and right here is made me to
yeah how old was she then she was 33 go
back to the Riverside where they find
his body they pick you who picks him up
by the way and moves him to the funeral
sheriff Strider was there one of his
deputies was there
they brought a black Undertaker there to
handle the body and Papa Mose was
summoned to to identify him because the
word obviously it was out that this kid
was missing so the first call went to
him and he identified the body and then
sheriff Strider ordered that the body be
buried immediately that day what
happened mother Mobley insisted when she
got news that they were preparing to
bury Emmitt in Mississippi she insisted
that he be returned to her in Chicago
and Papa Mose worked with one of mother
Mobley
cousins Crosby Smith to make sure that
he was brought back to Chicago and
Crosby Smith who is one of the closest
cousins vowed that he would bring him
back if he had to drive a truck and pack
him and ice and and drive him himself
but they were able to get the body
released as I mentioned it was released
under seal and orders not to open the
box and her cousin Crosby rode the train
back with him its body the city of New
Orleans frame which brought him back on
on Friday September 2nd and she was
there at the train station to to greet
the body one of the pictures you showed
earlier was her reaction to the the box
that was unloaded there and you know at
this point it all became so real to her
and as she described that box I mean it
was it was huge and she's such a little
woman she's barely five feet tall but
she nearly collapsed at that that moment
and there behind her is the man she
would later marry gene Mobley who was
there to comfort her throughout and the
two ministers who
who helped her through the the grieving
and the the funeral married to Jean
Mobley for with him at least 42 years I
don't see that long
when did the public first hear about
this and how much did the black press
what kind of role the black press play
the Chicago Defender and Jet magazine
and things like that in this story well
the Chicago Defender had been covering
horrible crimes like this for some time
it was probably one of the few places
where you could actually see coverage of
lynchings you know the Black Press was
was determined to carry pictures of the
Atlanta Daily world the Chicago Defender
all of the black newspapers carry these
stories so the reporters were used to
covering this kind of story Jet magazine
also did its part in in covering what
the the crimes against against blacks so
a number of black newspapers and Jet
magazine sent reporters down to to
Sumner to cover the trial in fact the
Jet magazine and ebony sent a team of
reporters and so did the defender the
defender had several editions including
a tri-state defender that was published
out of Memphis you said Jet magazine
sent a black reporter in a white
photographer yes why was that well the
publisher John H Johnson believed that a
white photographer would be able to get
into places that a black photographer
wouldn't and he was right about that I
mean the the black reporters were there
as you saw there were restrictions on
their movement in the courtroom that
there were also restrictions on their
movement in the larger community the one
of the incredible stories that came out
of this story was how black reporters
were determined to move beyond the
boundaries that have been set for them
they were there to cover a story but
they were also black people who knew
what we all were confronting at that
time in that place and there was a
problem that the investigation of this
crime ran into a number of witnesses
were disclosed in the black community
but they had not been brought forward
the prosecution had no resources with
which to invest
gave the crime and to carry it forward
so close to the time of trial there were
it looked like there were only going to
be two witnesses for the prosecution
Papa Mo's who could testify and identify
the the people who had come into his
home so he could testify to the
kidnapping and his son Simeon it was 12
at the time they were going to bring him
in to establish that the ring identified
in its body and that was it
but there were people who had seen
various aspects of this crime unfolding
as I mentioned people who had had
identified Roy Bryant and JW Milam at
the Sheridan plantation in sunflower
County had seen Emmitt in the back of a
truck had heard the beating there were
people out there who had these stories
to tell and the issue at the time was to
bring them forward to make sure that
they testify and the black reporters
participated in that search at the time
there were many people who worked in the
cotton fields in the Mississippi Delta
and they of course didn't trust white
people so to have a sheriff's deputy
come out into the field and asked them
to come forward was something that
terrified them and they wouldn't have
come thinking that they would be in
great peril themselves so the black
reporters helped to bring them out the
trial was held in what city in Sumner
them well had shaken Tallahatchie County
was what kind of a court was at County
State it was the the county court the
jury how many people in the jury there
were 12 white men were women allowed to
sit in the jury then not at that time
now and 12 white men right the judge was
a white man yes all the principals in
this case will like the judge the
prosecutors and the defense attorneys
obviously it's interesting there were
five lawyers practicing in Tallahatchie
County during this time and all five of
them volunteered to work for the defense
that's one of the defense attorneys the
defense attorneys on the right of your
screen and then JW Callum Callum and not
killing but Milam is in the middle yes
and Bryant is on the left hand side
right the trial lasted how long it
lasted four days
how long were those days
well some of them were shorter because
on the what was to be the first day of
trial after the jury was selected
there was a postponement because word
had reached the judge that there was a
belief there was some witnesses out
there who could come forward and offer a
very helpful testimony so they postponed
until the next day that was a short day
generally it was from about 9:00 in the
morning until the late afternoon the
temperature very hot apparently the
temperature was in the 90s outside but
his mother Mobley described in the court
it felt like 118 degrees and even hotter
when you consider the tension the
terrible tension that existed in that
dead courtroom were there any live
microphones in the room or television or
film no there are pictures that I've
seen published of different parts of the
interior but the judge had ordered early
on that there would be no more
photography after the initial stages of
jury selection there would be no more
photography in the courtroom during the
proceeding the picture you saw of Mose
Wright pointing out the murderers in the
case it was a picture that was taken
secretly by one of the black
photographers Ernest Wizards who was
quite a hero throughout the the civil
rights movement himself covering many
many important stories at great risk to
his own life he was there at the the
angle you see there is from the the Jim
Crow table and that's a cropped picture
but when you see the full image you can
see that he's shooting between some
people at the table and he just sort of
pops off a shot instantly at that
precise moment and to show you how
important that photo was one of the wire
services apparently saw him do that and
bought the film right out of his camera
there's a lot of details they were not
gonna have time to go to India in the
trial but they jury met for how long
after this trial was over just a little
more than an hour 67 minutes and during
that the period of 67 minutes they took
a coke break because they were asked to
make it look good you said that cokes
could not be bought by blacks right why
the vendors who
moved in and out of the courtroom would
not sell to blacks why because they were
discriminating against Blacks it was a
horrible period of race hatred and and
so mother mowgli made the mistake of
trying to buy something at one point she
was insulted as a result now when they
verdict was announced what was it and
what happened the verdict was not guilty
but even before that as mother Mobley
had recalled when the the jury was sent
out to deliberate she looked around the
courtroom she heard the closing
arguments
she was quite moved by what the
prosecution had had put out there but
she looked around and she saw the
expressions on the faces of the black
people in particular who was standing
around at the rear of this packed
courtroom and she realized then that
they were starting to move out of the
courtroom because they didn't want to be
around when the inevitable verdict came
in she knew that it was going to be not
guilty and she turned to congressman
Diggs and said I think it's time for us
to go and she remembers that the
congressman said well you want to leave
now you don't want to hear the verdict
she said I don't think this is a verdict
we want to be around to hear and all of
the black principals who came down for
the trial were staying in nearby mound
Bayou which was an all-black town they
all got in the cars and and left to
return to mound Bayou and just before
they hit was about an hour away an
hour's drive just at the time they were
approaching Mountain bio she said she
heard the report on the radio and it
sounded like the fourth of July because
it was such a celebration among the
whites in town that that these two men
were acquitted this only because of time
but I want to jumble of totally out of
context in a story to this quote it's by
Roy Wilkins former head of the NAACP
you're trying to capitalize on the death
of your son unquote page 207 that that
tells a whole story that you actually
I'm interested why she went into all
this story about what happened to her
afterwards
and the whole issue of money but again
I'll read it you're trying to capitalize
on the death of your son what's that
about well she went out on a speaking
tour
immediately after the trial this was a
period of a great financial strain for
the civil rights movement the
n-double-a-cp had spent all of its
resources human resources and money on
the brown decision there were several
cases that were decided with brown they
had been building these cases for 15
years this in double ACP was was
strapped at the time and as a result of
the speaking tour they were able to
raise quite a bit of money and we saw
this in reports that other newspapers
had put out thousands and thousands of
dollars were raised at these rallies
where she attended they negotiated a
deal where she was to receive I guess
100 $150 per speaking engagement was
quite a bit of money there's no question
about it there was at one point the
proposal that she do at or out west in
California and by this time there were a
number of people as I learned who were
who were representing her who were
negotiating for her she had struck a
deal with with Roy Wilkins she had met
him and was engaged by him there was no
question about that but then at a
certain point there were other people
representing her and I don't know that
they were representing her best interest
I even read reports about this from the
time that there were people who were
trying to negotiate I guess for more
money they had convinced her that if she
did the tour she would not have enough
money to pay all of her own expenses and
she needed to to ask for more money so
with her authorization I guess they
press for that and I guess a dispute
developed and at a certain point Roy
Wilkins called her himself and and
that's when he made that comment that
she recalled and it was quite hurtful to
her I mean it broke her heart for a
couple of reasons one because she was
not trying to pursue the money issue
herself but other people were pursuing
it on her behalf
she offered to forget about the money
which leads to the second reason it was
so hurtful to her at this time she was
still grieving the loss of her son it
was a terribly painful experience one
that you know we can't even match
and at a certain point when you're
grieving people kind of expect that
you're going to move on so she couldn't
really talk to friends and family after
a certain point but in making these
these public addresses that she made
speaking of crowds of up to 10,000
people at a time
she was able to continue to grieve it
was cathartic for her and she knew now
that that was going to be cut off and
that hurt her deeply because she had to
contain all of it and as you see in the
book at a certain point after this she
reached the brink of of considering
suicide
did she make a lot of money office not
that I know of as she never described a
great deal of money that she made and
other people who knew about her at the
time couldn't see a lot of money that
she was making and of course a hundred
one hundred fifty dollars a speech was
was quite a bit of money at that time
but she left her job and she had other
expenses she was also providing for her
father who would accompany or so I don't
know that she netted a great deal of
money it was how long did it take you
all to talk this out we talked for the
six months that she was that she was
around after we met starting in June for
she on dialysis and she was on dialysis
three times a week it's a great strain
on her and she she still was trying to
maintain an active speaking you know
speaking engagements so we fitted in
whenever we could and at a certain point
we were talking three or four days a
week
formally and in between those sessions
so quite quite a few hours during the
she lied she was a beautiful person she
she had the most incredible aura that
surrounded her that you you you you saw
immediately when you met her and she was
she was so full of love that was one of
the most incredible things that you
notice when you first met her she had no
bitterness at all it was one of the most
interesting things that I saw was that
she was opposed to capital punishment
she never wanted the murderers of her
son to be executed she only wanted them
to be sorry for what they had done she
only wanted the state of Mississippi to
express its apology as well so those are
the things that was striking about her
when did she die and under what
circumstances she died in January 2003
of
massive heart attack she was preparing
to go to Atlanta for speaking engagement
and she died the day before she was to
leave what impacted this whole thing
have on you well certainly as I
mentioned story of Emmett Till hasn't
been with me most of my life so I
thought it was an incredible experience
to have the chance to just meet Emmett
Till's mother but then to have the
chance to help her tell her story was
was irresistible
she mentioned as I as I told you she
mentioned that she wanted to do a book
and it took me all of two seconds to
decide that I wanted to help her with it
and we work that out immediately to have
had a hand in in telling the story I
think is quite a unique experience I was
too young to take part in the civil
rights movement but now I feel that I
have participated in telling this story
you know it's you can't really
understand where we are now without
knowing something of the history of this
country in the latter part of the 20th
century and you can't understand that
story without knowing the civil rights
movement and you really don't fully
appreciate the civil rights movement
without knowing the Emmett Till story so
now I understand that and it's been
quite a moving experience for me and
when it helped me to renew my own
personal commitment this is a woman who
who lived a committed life she lived on
purpose every moment of her life
following the son of her felony the
murder of her son and she inspired that
in so many other people who were touched
by her and I certainly was one of those
people and this photograph on the cover
of the book how old was he and where was
this taken email he was 13 years old at
the time that photo was taken and that
was taken at their last Christmas
celebration together she for some reason
was moved to to make that Christmas the
most special one ever not knowing that
it would be their last one together so
she spent an awful lot of money on gifts
and a big dinner and then she decided
she wanted to memorialize it by having
pictures made she it had no pictures
made of him it when when he was growing
up after his childhood and he was 13 at
that time so she decided to have
pictures made that's one of the famous
shots of him and her together the other
one he showed of him leaning on the
was shot at that time as well and
there's another famous shot of him with
a wide brim hat on that was a Christmas
gift that he had received at the time so
she was quite proud of that that
Christmas celebration and wanted to
memorialize it not knowing that those
would be the last photographs ever taken
of him alive
they were also posted on his casket so
his people filed by they saw his body
but they saw with what he had been like
before he was brutalized christopher
Benson has been our guest and the story
told to him by Mamie till Mobley cover
the book again death of innocence thank
you very much for joining us it's been
my pleasure